في هذه الاثناء قالت المتحدثه باسم
المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين رولا امين ان العائقه امام ادخال
المساعدات الى سوريا هو تعطل الطريق
الرئيس الى معبر باب الهوى بسبب الزلزله
وان هناك املا ان ينتهي اصلاحه اليوم
ليتسنى ادخال المساعدات وادعت في لقاء مع
الجزيره جميع الاطراف والدول الى وضع
الخلافات السياسيه جانبا لادخال المساعدات
بشكل اكبر عبر اكثر من معبر وذلك لحاجه
الشعب السوري الماسه لكثير من المساعدات
مجلس الامن والامين العام هم من يقومون
بهذا التحرك لا اعرف باي اتجاه نحن
كمنظمات اغاثيه موجوده على الارض لا ندخل
في هذه النقاشات نحن نحث ونطلب
ونناشد ونقول الحاجات كبيره ورجاء من جميع
الاطراف وجميع الدول وضع الخلافات
السياسيه جانبا ووضع التسجيل النقاط
السياسيه جانبا والتركيز على تلبيه
احتياجات الناس هذه هي مناشدتنا الامين
العام والمكتب المكتب يعني الجزء في الامم
المتحده المسؤول عن العلاقات السياسيه
ومجلس الامن هو من يقرر ايبت معابر تستطيع
المنظمات الانسانيه استعمالها